let's think about different ways that we
can represent the number six hundred
and seventy five
six hundred and seventy-five
so the most obvious way is to just look
at the different place values so the six
is in the hundreds place it literally
represents 600. so that's 600.
then that red color
600. the 7 is in the tens place it
represents 7 tens or 70.
and then the five is in the ones place
it represents five so let me copy and
paste this and then think about how we
can regroup the value in the different
places to represent this in different
ways
so let me copy and let me paste it and
maybe i'll do it three times so let me
do it once let me do it one more time
so one thing that we could do
is we could regroup from one place to
the next so for example we could take if
we wanted to we could take
one from the hundreds place
taking one from the hundreds place we'll
make this a five that's essentially
taking 100 away so this is really making
this a 500 and we could give that
hundred to well we could actually give
it to either place but let's give it to
the tens place so we're gonna give we're
gonna give a hundred
we're gonna give a hundred to the tens
place
now if you give a hundred to the tenths
place and you already had 70 there was
it going to be equal to well it's going
to be equal to 170.
well how would we represent that as tens
well 170 is 17 tens
so we could just say that 7 becomes a
17.
now we could keep doing that we could
regroup some of this value in the tens
place to the ones place so for example
we could give 10
from the tens place and give it to the
ones place let's do that so let's take
10 away from here so that becomes 160
this becomes
16 and let's give that 10
let's give that 10 to the ones place
well what does the ones place now become
well 10 plus 5
is 15. so this 5 is now a 15. let's do
another scenario let's take
let's do something let's do something
nutty let's take 200 from the hundreds
place
let's give take 200 from the hundreds
place so this is going to be now four
and this is going to become 400 that's
what this 4 now represents and let's
give 100 let's give 100 to the tens
place
and let's give another 100
to the ones place
so notice i'm just regrouping that two
hundreds those two hundreds i've taken
from the hundreds place and i'm going to
give it to these other places
so now the tens place is going to be
170.
we're going to we're going to have 170
here which is 17 tenths so you could say
the tens place is now 17.
and now the ones place well i had five
and i'm going to add a 100 to it so it's
going to be 105.
it's going to be 105 and 105 ones is
literally 105. and notice this is 400
plus 17 tens which is 170 plus 105 you
add these together you're still going to
get 675.
let's do
that again
so let's take
i don't know let's take
let's take all of the hundreds away
let's take all of the hundreds away so
that goes zero that goes zero and let's
give
400 to the tens place
so let's give 400 to the tens place
well that'll make that 470.
let me do that in that green color
that'll make that 470 which is the same
thing as 47
47 tens and then i still have 200 to
give to the ones place
so let me do that so i still have 200 to
and so that's going to go from 5 to 205
to 205. once again all i've done is i've
regrouped the value
in the number numbers 675 any of these
still represent 675. you can add these
numbers on the right they all add up to
675.